mais je sais pas si tu peux en parler si
c'était une prof d'allemand en quatrième
qui était très belle et qui me pousser à
venir en cours pour le regarder la
première fois qu'elle m'est apparu c'est
une grande dame blonde avec des lances
jusqu'au dos j'étais juste prévenir fait
puis j'étais drôlement surpris parce que
je ne voyais pas sa tête c'était disons
une ombre qui venait je voyais que son
devoir jeter déroulement surpris puis
c'est une femme dont la vie qui était
relativement ouverte et à travers ça au
fur et à mesure je ne sais pas si c'est
dû à mon âge vous n'importe quoi si
c'était peut-être ma crise depuis vers
sotchi
je suis complètement tombe amoureux
d'elle c'est alors c'était assez dur
parce que je me souviens avec un copain
est lui par contre j'étais amoureux que
la prof de maths alors à la fin c'était
on faisait plus ou moins des boum et
tout cela on invitait la prof a dansé
dans cette c'était drôlement sympathique
et je sais que ça c'est l'année de
français où j'ai eu dix ans notre
j'étais complètement fasciné il fait
l'affront que je bosse pour bon je me
fasse remarquer à canon et océ joue si
ça joue ici un prof de maths en première
extraordinaire
tout à fait j'ai failli et de prof de
maths à cause de lui
enfin prendre de philo dont j'étais
amoureuse ça c'est bon inévitable cas si
elle m'a marqué parce que ont déjà voir
son aspect on rigolait souvent de lui
parce qu'il faisait beaucoup de gestes
et mais il était particulièrement
accession enfin chez moi j'avais
l'impression d'être toujours sollicité
par exemple il y avait un exercice à
faro tableau c'était au hasard l'a dit
avec tout ce qu'il m'a appelé par mon
nom c'était 120 et tout le monde
rigolait à chaque fois parce que tout le
monde savait que des branchés sur moi
enfin chez pol
déjà ce son allure c'était quelqu'un de
c'était une femme qui était très grande
très forte et bon elle imposait vraiment
et elle l'aimé on impose y aller me
faire peur aux élèves
mais une fois qu'on la connaissait bien
c'était quelqu'un d'extraordinaire qui
avait d'abord une culture étonnante et
puis qui a su nous en apporter quand
même il nous en reste un peu et ça c'est
bien je crois
ça serait plutôt un chef d'établissement
qui m'a marqué c'est pas du tout la même
chose mon fils m'a c'était mon directeur
de l'école primaire et c'était un homme
je considérais même comme mon grand-père
c'était vraiment même lui il les lit de
m'apprécier je savais qu'il m'appréciait
et samaa je sais pas comment dire mais
encore maintenant jeu on s'écrit en
correspond je suis allé le voir chez lui
il est actuellement à la retraite et ça
même si tout le monde avait pas une fois
une relation comminges avec lui tout le
monde l'apprécié à sa juste valeur parce
qu'ils étaient litres sévère ils étaient
strictes il était l'été austère et il
fallait savoir percer là la carapace j'y
suis arrivé j'avoue je me demandais
qu'est ce que c'était en fait je dis
d'où ils nous sortent celui-là c'est
vrai parce que j'avais pas l'habitude
d'avoir un prof comme ça mais il a la
personnalité moi je trouve ça bien et il
montre dès le départ que c'est lui qui a
l'autorité c'est pas nous on n'a pas le
droit de faire le bordel c'est mon prof
de physique ce que ben on va déjà
j'étais pas vraiment attiré par cette
matière vingt six ans même que j'en ai
fait horreur et il s'en est rendu compte
dès le premier cours est
il se demandait un petit peu pourquoi
parce que pour lui la physique c'était
vraiment le summum c'était la matière la
plus intéressant et il y avait de ça et
à une réunion avec mes parents il leur a
demandé qu'est ce qu'il y avait et quand
il a su que j'aimais pas il a changé du
tout au tout avant de l'essayer de
m'intéresser et de ce jour là quand il y
avait plus ou moins des cours quand même
qui intéressent et il me disait non
mademoiselle dormez dormez c'est très
bien vous n'avez pas besoin de ça et ben
en fait pas la première impression qui
compte le plus
toute façon on voit mon prof de maths
arriver avec des lunettes je me suis
rien alors là là on se dit ça y est
cette année on va faire chier quoi ces
ports un prof qui vivra mons en cours
qui qui fait son cours comme s'il
faisait une pièce de théâtre bon ça peut
être qu'intéressant
la prof sympa un acteur un peu vrai et
le public est toujours bon enfin ça
dépend où c'est dur pour l'acteur de foi
est quelqu'un que j'aimerais vous qu on
voir pour me dire quoi pour lui dire
qu'on l'a pas oublié que c'est quelqu'un
qui a été important et puis que bonbons
que je crois que c'est le plus beau
cadeau qu'on puisse lui faire lui dire
on vous a pas oublié c'était vraiment
vous on aimait aller à votre coup même
s'il ya des moments où on en avait marre
et vous ne faisiez pas réciter pas bien
mais bon je crois que c'est le plus beau
cadeau qu'on puisse faire un prof en
disant moment vous êtes toujours là
[Musique]